c'est un rapport publié lundi provenant
du haut conseil à l'égalité femmes
hommes qui explique que les émissions de
télé réalité diffusée en france et est
pourvoyeuse de sexisme parmi les
émissions visée on retrouve les
marseillais versus le reste du monde les
anges de la télé réalité mais aussi plus
étonnant l'émission koh lanta la saison
passée au crible par le haut conseil
concerne 2019 et selon eux ces émissions
présente les candidates sous le prisme
de femmes stupide faible et rival
concernant koh lanta ce sont les plans
hyper sexualisée des candidates qui
semble poser problème
mais aujourd'hui alexia laroche joubert
la productrice du programme a décidé de
répondre
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'elle n'est pas content et de piquant
et paillotes pas impuni la sexualisation
il me semble que corps en plein été pour
la côte basque et les hommes et les
femmes
cela veut dire qu'elle veut on l'a dit
les femmes
pour elle cette commission sort
totalement de son rôle avec ses
remarques très en colère alexia laroche
joubert a demandé un rendez-vous à la
ministre marlène schiappa bref on sent
que cette histoire va finir en épreuve
des poteaux
c'est ouf
quoi et ouais ouais ouais la demande et
moi marlène schiappa elle a eu
rendez-vous d'ailleurs avec marlène
schiappa voilà on va peut-être temps et
on va essayer d'appeler marlène schiappa
dont la star n'est pas du tout au
courant
chaque fois découvrir qualité dans le
bail alors les chéris qu'est ce que vous
en pensez parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de gens voilà qui dit ça ils ont
même fait un rapport est ce que
voulaient voir quelques extraits d'abord
pour voir de quoi il parle et de quoi il
en retourne en entier par exemple
regarder on a par exemple un extrait
dont on va prendre un extrait des
marchés née marseillais c'est très
simple regardez il ya il ya beaucoup de
voix là ils sont débrouillés une vidéo
qui avait fait énormément politique
c'est pas dans les marchés et d'ailleurs
c'est dans les songes
on y voyait notamment le candidat
ricardo piqué une colère parce que l'une
de ses camarades ne voulait pas revenir
le ménage ça c était une des séquences
qui a été retenu par la commission
garder mais il faut passer la
serpillière
c'est ce que jouer gc j'ai envie de te
prends mon temps pour passer le balai tu
veux pas le faire
le cpo longtemps c'est de reprendre
longtemps oui 300 questions à lire comme
ça mais j'ai aussi comme toi alors tu
veux
le con je vais te faire vivre un enfer
je vais faire un jeu de malin on va
jouer je dire je vais te faire vivre un
enfer
[Musique]
alors dans leur rapport qu'est ce que
dit le haut conseil à l'égalité lapone
du programme le plus sexistes revient
aux marseillais de w9 et ben ex-aequo
avec les anges de nrj 12 milliards merci
d'être là ils disent les femmes
présentent des caractéristiques
comportementales stéréotypé
s'apparentant soit au cliché de la femme
bimbo il soit ceux de la partenaire
idéale ou idéalisée les candidats sont
considérés comme des dons jeu en
dominateur et les candidates comme des
séductrices que ce soit en bikini dans
la maison en peignoir transparent et
talons aiguilles au petit déjeuner dans
la salle commune la télé réalité montre
au public des femmes sexualisé même dans
des contextes qui ne s'y prête pas
ordinairement voilà je vous le dis en
août une autre vidéo par exemple
kkj à marquer voilà le haut conseil et
l'égalité il ya beaucoup de séduction
dedans si on se souvient d'un extrait
avec une danse de king long et fait
énormément réagir regarder siglos
attaque massive
[Applaudissements]
qui passe mais devant moi et commencé là
c'est très bien lancé allah allah le
corps pour halal super corps et
franchement ça donne des idées pour la
suite
si tu crois que montrer tes fesses et
ouvrir tes jambes c'est sa garde et un
homme
ben c'est peut-être pour ça que tu était
célibataire jusqu'à présent eu les
marseillais miss france koh lanta des
émissions excitant à voir un extrait des
marseillais de koh lanta dans un instant
qu'ils trouvent que wixson des émissions
sexiste mathieu a mais c'est un club à
part koh lanta je vois pas comment on
peut être content
non non pas du tout de deux choses
évidemment les marseillais pardon bah
quand on regarde on sait très bien que
l'on voit que des filles avec des seins
comme ça débouche comme ça et forcément
si j'étais producteur serait pareil on
ne prend que les phrases très drôle
ouais la guerre de 45-55 deuxième guerre
mondiale anota pas de shampooing donc on
est montre totalement qui comme le font
les rohff est une insulte à et petits 2
pour les miss france les ses fils que
mes animaux que nous désirons un
concours animalier et après c'est je
suis contre la guerre alors beaucoup
montrent des filles entièrement refaits
sur l'île du ramier nationale et dieu il
peut vous dire quelque chose près avec
pas d'accord avec vous passez alors
qu'elle n'est pas du tout la même tous
les mecs ils ont ils sont ils sont toute
la journée en maillot c'est aussi les
jeunes et on les a réussis les conneries
pareilles conneries je vous le dis sont
moins drôles sont peut-être moins drôle
tous les combats moins drôle parce que
je m'interdis dire c'est caricatural que
c'est parfois même un peu vulgaire tout
ce que tu vas y c'est pas du tout
sexistes les hommes et les femmes sont
mis sur un ping m
il correspond aux indiens au style
d'émission qui correspond aux jeunes là
où tu peux y ait un peu de sexisme peut
par exemple des clips de rap où les mecs
sont tous habillés montaut le feu il est
là son bikini en string à côté d'eux
mais là les émissions télé est dans les
marseille par exemple j'ai jamais vu un
mec avec un tee shirt que dans les six
toute la journée les fans des héros faut
faire des trucs aussi à langoiran
extrêmement sexy on va voir un extrait
vidéo
c'est ce qu'explique le rapport de la
haute surveillance de l'égalité hommes
femmes
c'est que dans des émissions de télé
réalité les femmes seraient tout le
temps en quête de séduction c'est ça
qu'il a les armes aussi il ya un extrait
dans les marseillais on voit que tout on
a donc un objectif séduire mon poto paga
regarde mon âme sans envie de gagner des
points déjà porté couronnaises
s'affrontent et après si tu veux cyr a
sauvé la zone est ce que tu préfères
bibi océane
mais je te jure il va pas te répondre on
est je le connais très bien cela la
village et décide de me faire belle pour
les tenues sont pas tous des sea dogs
avec ma banque décide de les customiser
en coupe un petit peu tout ça quoi être
un couple sexy faire un peu plus apte à
kamsar j'apprends que j'étais sensuelle
sexy
ben je suis trop contente une petite
vengeance vis-à-vis de vagues a alors
dit non j'ai dit soyez patient
marseillais pardon les enjeux qui sont à
parité ne pas de métisses part dans 1100
à parité 2-2 musculature les hommes et
les phares ils sont exactement sur le
même pied d'égalité dans capable de
s'extraire du tout c'est peut-être
caricatural et vulgaire mais ça n'a rien
de sexiste et quant à koh lanta je suis
désolé c'est pas du tout le même genre
de mission au chu et vous suis désolé si
pour moi c'est pas caricatural et
vulgaire c'est juste ça représente des
jeunes plein de jeunes qui se retrouvent
dans les mares 6 avril et dans l'est
certains aimeraient via les ailes plein
de bon sens et intelligent déjà sa bonne
condition je connais je vous promets je
reviens fois oui oui vous savez qu'elle
est très intelligent dans la vie à
l'antenne à tâtons et bien on vous a
beaucoup entendu s'arrête chez moi chez
vous moi je vais vous dire quelque chose
j'arrête je vous le dis ça me saoule moi
c'est a priori on a sur ses émissions là
je suis désolé les marseillais y en a
plein qui parle comme dans les versets
vous croyez que les marseillais c'est un
village gaulois là que des mecs les mecs
qui parlent d'eux mais ils sont tous
dans les marseillais où ils sont tous
dans les anges
arrêtez de dire des bêtises ça
représente une grosse une grosse partie
de la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui est
forcément
et bah ils sont représentés sur w9 ou
sur nrj 12 dans une émission secrètement
il faut arrêter de dire c'est des fous
c'est des débiles ou cédric c'est pas
des débiles les produits à l'heure de
montre que ce qui était bio mais oui
normal
oui là qu'est ce que tu en penses bon
merci hein parce que je vois que tout le
monde a l'air très concerné par le sujet
où il est conscient des mois pour avoir
fait urbain 5 en 5 ans des missions j'ai
fait à peu près neuf émissions en tout
j'ai jamais ressenti un comportement
sexiste à mon égard après je pense que
tout dépend comment se pose ici qu'on
vous demande de vous habiller un peu
mais pas sexy mais pas du tout pas du
tout mais alors elle s'ouvre demain tu
fais une émission d'aventuré on n'a pas
envie d'être en bon d'être jolie de ce2
bien ta vie' regarde je suis venu ce
soir j'ai voulu me faire joli mais est
ce que ce sera pire ou 6 rue a pas du
tout parce que là ce soir tout le monde
est très jolie tout le monde est bien
habillé je pense que même clément s'est
même clémence et son style qu'on et
après on se rappelle que des filles soit
disant bimbo qu'on les seins refaits etc
mais dans chaque émission et défis qui
sont complètement différente à défis qui
sont super naturel tel défi quand une
personnalité discrète chouette c'est ce
qui fait un petit peu le programme là ce
qui est triste malheureusement c'est
qu'en fait on ne montre qu'un extrait
pour en fait dire voilà c'est sexiste
alors qu'en vrai il faut juger une
émission par son ambition dans les
épisodes donné mais moi je moi je trouve
que si vous représentez une partie de la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui je vois pas où
est le problème
je suis désolé je trouve qu'ils vont
chercher des problèmes là où il y en a
pas pour sa part au choix s'étant
koh-lanta excuse ou presque alors mais
dans koh lanta en maillot de bain bah
oui tu veux surtout pas faire koh lanta
en doudoune nadal or justement arrêté
on va revenir sur koh lanta parce qu'il
ya des signatures montré les deux
séquences qui ont choqué la commission
sur koh lanta il ya une séquence ya un
candidat qui tient des propos polémiques
sur ces séquences et une autre aventure
hier et il déclare entre autres que la
candidate est une cagole ce qui a énervé
la haute surveillance regarde et il
était vénère doux
[Musique]
par le compare déjà pour la confiance
cindy elle a le profil type de la blonde
un peu limité au premier abord mais elle
est très très intelligente pas bête du
tout - one là alors ça c'est un dérapage
mais partout voilà mais c'est pas mais
en fait je vous dirais la deuxième
séquence de koh lanta ya aussi inès qui
a fait beaucoup parler d'elle à cause de
son string lors d'une épreuve
j'étais pas pour remettre cette séquence
les prout faut qu'on monte ce cas pas
plus olivier à la haute surveillance
et j'aurais défaut d'un format de monter
aux arbres
non franchement non je veux pas voir ça
mais non il faut voir là l'extrait que
les joutes poursuivre
inès va développer son ascension
côté pour pouvoir chacun prend un fils
thomas barral et la quatrième corps d'un
fixe et inès doit tricoter son échelle
il faut que la corde soit bien tendu à
choquer alors j'ai gardé ses émissions
ce qui se fera par la jirs tout le monde
déchiré va pas rester huit ce qui me
gêne beaucoup d'abord de la part du haut
conseil c'est le côté donneur de leçons
je suis la voix les gens font leur
travail
on leur a demandé de le faire oui mais
je vous dis moi sera alors je trouve
qu'il est trop donneurs de leçons après
y'a des terriers bientôt grâce à
notamment
je suis désolé moi je trouve que c'est
sexiste l'image d'inès avec son string
que c'est une image qui a été fait pour
tirer koh lanta vers une télé réalité la
loi mais les arrange parce qu'elle est
plus utile là ça peut vous déranger
chouinard m oui bon je crois quand même
que c'est sexiste de dire que c'est sexy
elle s'habille comme elle veut la ligue
des landes s'habille comme elle est
établie comme il veut dans la vie
et si elle veut représente se
représenter comme ça elle le fait de
renoncer aux mondiaux et aux rues un mec
en string personnes n'ont rien n'oblige
les personnes on aurait rigolé c'est pas
une question de d'habillement ont peut
être effectivement comme vous le dites
très féministe et féminines à la fois ça
c'est pas un problème mais vous a dit
comme vous voulez il ya des propos
machistes danser télé réalité là mais
dans notre programme que vous ne pouvez
pas accepter mais comme partout dans la
drogue
moi en fait ce qui me dérange c'est que
c'est trop facile de toujours s'attaque
à la télé réalité
ben ahmed quand vous regardez autour de
vous il ya plein de métiers et skema
moi j'ai rarement vu des femmes éboueurs
vous en voyez vous non mais ça sert très
sexy ça n'a pas trop faire de sexy je
dis oui mais ça n'a rien à voir
est-ce que c'est toujours facile en fait
de s'attaquer à la télé réalité de dire
que les problèmes de sexy c'est moi
toutes ces émissions je les ai faites
maintenant c'est une question de
caractère soi ricard dont on prend
l'exemple de riz cadre il ne fait plus
télé réalité aujourd'hui de ces aides a
rejoint son père voilà et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les producteurs
et qu'aujourd'hui on fait attention
justement on a des contrats où il ya
écrit qu' on essaye de deux des propos
sexistes islamophobe et c'est tout ça on
est vite parce que c'est pas l'image que
donnait ça marche pas je vais vous dire
juste la représentation des femmes en
télé 42% des femmes à l'antenne pour un
taux de parole de 32 % c'est-à-dire qu'à
42 % de femmes 58 % donnent seulement
29% entre 21h et 23h
le pourcentage de femmes parmi les
intervenants politiques à la télévision
et de 27 % celui des experts 13 % et 12
% des fictions sont écrites par des
femmes seulement 8% des fictions sont
réalisés par des femmes
le bus et bien c'est fait par une femme
bravo puisque mine de rien ces
capitaines marleau qui cartonne la
puissance eric donc voilà même
américaine s'appuie tout mettre ses
capitaines marleau qui marche le plus
longue haleine bindu mm mais il a dit
non merci alors vraiment sur moi moi moi
je respecte les gens qui regardent ce
projet parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui regarde ce programme réno ne sont
pas la cible parce que se lever le matin
et déjà est totalement en peignoir fait
du mal les mecs sont tous tatoués et ils
font tout 70 kg moi ça me record reste
je peux pas je suis pas tatoués et
j'approche des sens qu'ils ont misé sur
la tunisie les propos si c'est le cas
j'ai regardé la team en talons j'ai
regardé un petit peu sur les propos tu
dis les propos sont pas sexiste combien
de fois c'est bip et où un mec manque de
respect une femme mais parce que sa télé
réalité dans l'aveyron un jour que cette
même raison fait interrompre ce n'est
pas une raison pour de l'accès à moins
de 14 ans comme cyril et 10 14 16 ans
vous pouvez parler comme ça mais c'est
comme ça qu'on devait parler aux femmes
pourquoi il ya des d'huile comme ça
j'avais alors on va voir on va voir le
symbole psychogène on va on va clore le
débat les chiffres puisque on a plein de
trucs à faire
oui à 46% non à 54 équilibré mais c'est
une clôture et moi moi j'aime passer
j'aime pas ses émissions alors moi je
pense qu'on regarde pour vous relooker
mesure mater et pour se moquer de vous
je vous mets ça va forcément répondu
absolument
caen est absolument mais on est là pour
donner son point de vue après moi je
sais pas tellement que c'est sexiste
moi je trouve qu'il ya une esthétique
pornographiques dans ces émissions qui
ne me dérange pas du tout parce qu après
tout vous êtes sur la plage vous avez le
droit de bêtes n'importe quel maillot
vous êtes magnifique vous avez bien
raison et pareil pour les garçons en
revanche moi ce que j'aime pas c'est la
manière dont on stéréotypes les rapports
entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est toujours dans l'écrit chaud dans
l'hystérie
je trouve que c'est justement
dévastateur pour la jeunesse et pour
jour milk est beaucoup plus vieux parce
que justement la fausse complètement les
rapports des médias tiago ouais c'est
votre avis je trouve que vous parfois
vous mettez votre cas de vos casquettes
de vieux con mais c'est pas grave et
sérieux la façon d'attribuer vous avez
raison de la bête on les insulte est
d'accord t'es d'accord qu'un mec insulte
une armée c'est normal que quand vous
êtes en réunion avec un autre genre un
moment ça peut déraper ici combien de
fois ça a dérapé
mais voilà et bien sûr ces mecs aussi
bien sur les voiles aluminium ainsi
aujourd'hui c'est bip et essaie de faire
à temps sur les